qui d'autre préféreriez-vous que le destin
du monde
soit entre leurs mains qui d'autre vous savez doit me
battre je peux le gérer vous
tous
ta
responsabilité
seule l'
une des principales choses que mon père
euh euh a
inculqué était l'éducation mon père était
très
dur pour élargir ton esprit chaque jour en
apprenant et il était euh il était dans l'
armée donc
c'était une question de discipline
[Musique]
quand j'ai commencé  écrire des rimes en
ouais probablement 80, c'est quand j'ai vraiment
commencé à m'asseoir et à écrire des rimes et
j'écrivais des
raps dans mon livre et j'avais mes mots de quatre lettres
là-dedans vous savez
j'écrivais toutes mes affaires et ma grand-mère
a trouvé mon rap  livre
et elle a écrit une lettre au
dos de mon livre de rap elle a dit cher
willard c'est ma grand-mère qui m'a appelé
willard elle a dit cher willer
les gens vraiment intelligents n'ont pas besoin d'utiliser
des mots comme ça pour s'exprimer
quand j'ai commencé à faire le nouveau prince
de bel air j'espérais juste avoir une
belle voiture un jour
les films que
j'ai fait
jouer un personnage trois fois pour moi
c'est comme à la maison
[Musique]
eh bien ils m'apprennent tous les jours qu'il n'y a
pas d'autre
but que de vivre complètement et pleinement
comme tu es tu le
sais et c'était une si nouvelle idée
comme eux, ce
sont deux des
personnes authentiques les plus puissantes comme vous le savez et et
vous savez, je suppose que jada et moi avons pu
leur donner une chose que
vous savez que nous voulions grandir là où ils
sont, ils sont juste
à l'aise et confiants d'être eux
sans  une préoccupation
de ce que les autres ressentent à ce sujet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
euh
[Musique]
muhammad ali a joué david à goliath
après goliath après goliath
et toujours il se lève et  je pense que c'est un
excellent message
[Musique]
pour le froid pour tout le monde
je dirai au président Mandela
l'inspiration que
vous m'avez donnée et
aux gens du monde entier vous
pouvez être assuré
que votre travail  votre engagement
vivra pour toujours
[Musique]
vous savez dans mon esprit que je suis un
euh un guerrier et j'enseigne à mon fils comment
chasser
et comment pourrais-je apprendre à
mon fils comment chasser autrement que d'apporter  lui
avec moi et nous sommes dans une interview et
c'est ce que je fais et c'est l'
entreprise
dans laquelle je travaille pour moi c'est euh c'est je ne peux pas
imaginer quelle est l'autre option
[Musique]
je me souviens du jour où
j'ai pris ma retraite je  littéralement dit à jada
c'est ça je me retire je me retire
d'essayer de te rendre heureux j'ai besoin que tu ailles
te faire plaisir et juste me prouver
que c'est même possible
jouer avec
des effets spéciaux de comédie dramatique c'est comme
tout ce que je me suis entraîné à
faire
au cours des 30 dernières années en tant
qu'artiste dans lequel je dois le faire
dans ce film c'est l'une des expériences les plus
agréables
de ma carrière
[Musique]
nous avons commencé à parler  à propos de nous sommes entrés dans
ce
faux concept romantique
selon lequel d'une manière ou d'une autre, lorsque nous nous sommes mariés, nous
deviendrions un et ce que nous avons réalisé, c'est que
nous étions deux personnes complètement séparées
sur deux voyages individuels complètement séparés
et que nous choisissions de faire
ensemble nos voyages séparés